BIG NIGHT FOR
SPORTS.
LOCAL BC SPORTS BOOK.
J.T. MILLEHNER.
HE HAS ROOM AND TIME.
AND UP AND OVER THE SHOULDER.
ROY.
KARLSSON.
FAKED ONE WAY.
AND COMING BACK WAS MILLELE MYEM
THE RIGHT POINT.O BE SHARP
THERE.
HERE IS JANMARK.
PASSING OFF
AND THEN JUSTETS THE PUCK BACK O
HUGHGHTED IN A FREAKY ONE.
HERE IS PETTERSSON IN FRONT.
TIPPED OFFTO TEE IT UP.
HE GETS OVER THERE.
AND HE PASSES THE
SENDS PETTERSSON AWAY.
PETTERSSON CUTS ACROSS THE SLOT
E
THEY THOUGHT IT WAS IN. GOAL LI?
LOOKS LIKE THEY ALREADY HAD
THEIR LOOK. OR FIVE REPLAYS
FOR MY GOOD EYES TO WOHEN AMADI.
HE C HANDS KNOCKS
IT OUT. UP BY PETTERSSON.
CANUCKS 2
IT'S A TWO ON
THERE'S THE FIRST SAVE.ACK.
DADONOV I
DADONOV HIT BY LAMMIKKO.FADING
DICKINSON TRYING TO PICK UP THE
PUCK.
COULDN'T. GO.
HUGHES MISSED THE PUCK AND IN
FRONT.
BLOCKED BY GARLAND WHO STEPHENS.
TRIED TO GET IT DOWN LOW OFF THE
AND SHEA THEODORE HAS HIS SECOND
OF THE GAM AND PETTERSSON AND
EKMAN-LARSSON WILL START OVER
TIME AND HORVAT
CUTS INTO THE SHOT AND STOP